bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir-là drôle de campagne de
marine le pen elle s'est faite discrète
depuis sa défaite à la présidentielle on
l'a dit démotivée mais depuis quelques
jours son parti sonne la mobilisation
générale aux législatives alors
pourra-t-elle s'imposer comme la
première force d'opposition à
l'assemblée face à un jean luc mélenchon
plutôt offensif que jamais que peut
espérer le rnc notre grand débat ce soir
un espion à la télévision vous l'avez
sans doute déjà vu sur les plateaux
notre grand témoin ce soir est un ancien
agent du kgb reconverti dans le
journalisme et les relations
internationales du public cette semaine
l'engrenage chez albin michel sur la
russie de poutine et les conséquences de
cette guerre qu'il a déclenchée en
ukraine sergueï smirnov est avec nous ce
soir enfin d'autres où vont nos a
franchi pour leur parti pris s d'amont
d'un gamin quand l'inquiétude monte dans
la majorité à deux semaines du scrutin
ce sera dans son carnet de campagne des
législatives l'économie avec fanny
guinochet la croissance est atone
l'inflation et record et la récession
menace et puis ils regardent e-label
lasserre sur cette grève inédite demain
des diplomates voilà pour le menu et
c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs ne lui dites surtout pas
qu'elle manque d'ambition dans cette
élection aura pratiquement dans toutes
les circonscriptions nous avons été
majoritaire au second tour pour peu que
nos électeurs se mobilisent nous avons
évidemment la capacité de gagner et moi
j'appelle les électeurs à se mobiliser
nous pouvons
être élu mais nous ne pourrons pas être
élu sans vous voilà marine le pen était
dans l'oise cet après midi et en
picardie ce matin pour faire taire les
mauvaises langues à leur parti trop tard
déjà agger démotivés est ce que c'est
vraiment le cas bonsoir pascal perrineau
bienvenue sur ce plateau est politologue
cevipof spécialiste de la sociologie
électorale et professeur à sciences po
paris bonsoir stéphane zumsteeg faire
vite vous retrouvez directeur du
département opinion de l'institut de
sondages ipsos comment travaillent les
sondeurs dans cette législative et et
que peut-on dire de ce qui peut se
passer pour le rassemblement national on
a hâte de vous entendre bonsoir paul lo
bâché et bienvenue sur ce plateau vous
êtes journaliste à l'opinion quotidien
dans lequel vous suivez le parti de
marine le pen est d'ailleurs celui
d'eric zemmour également reconquête
c'est intéressant parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'elle veut vraiment le
tuer dans cette élection va en parler
mais d'abord un vent de vous donner la
parole là me stéphane daquo ce qui pour
son billet tout de suite si j'ai bien
compris c'est lui qui nous plante le
décor comme chaque soir
[Musique]
bonsoir téva me faire dire des annonces
et j'aime bien que vous mettez vos
boutons de manchette
schéma news que vont penser les
téléspectateurs si j'ai bien compris ce
soir si j'ai bien compris marine le pen
vous me dites ainsi je me tourne n'a pas
l'intention
d'être élu à matignon ça on a cru
comprendre maintenant faut la comprendre
parce que quand même c'est le pire job
de la vème république et un premier
ministre d'ailleurs vous avez vu jean
castex comme il était pressé de partir
il n'en pouvait plus un pauvre oui mais
tout est à matignon ce n'est pas
l'opposition on peut pas se contenter de
critiquer il faut apporter des solutions
donc en clair c'est des emmerdes 7 jours
sur 7 déjà mais même 24 heures sur 24
dans ce bref plutôt que d'être à
matignon marieville très fair être
présidente de la république alors non
pas de la république je crois qu est l a
dit que la veille on avait marre à la
map à se re re re présenter en 2027 même
la présidence du parti a relaté
spécialiste en a d'autres mais bon en
tout cas elle a dit que ce n'était pas
tellement dans ses intentions actifs on
a l'impression aussi qu'elle pourrait
laisser la présidence donc du parti à
jordan barbera qui est pas mal ce petit
jeune d'air et donc son seul objectif
c'est donc de faire élire 15 députés
pourquoi 15 députés parce qu'on a un
gros parlementaire et qu'il serait la
présidente du groupe parlementaire je
vous laisse pas répondre à la réponse
venir vers moi je prendrais la tête du
groupe que j'espère le plus nombreux
possible
nous sommes arrivés en tête au second
tour des élections présidentielles dans
150 circonscriptions et dans ses 150
circonscriptions
nous avons la capacité de gagner les
élections législatives alors ça
changerait quoi d'avoir un groupe à
l'assemblée pour le rnd là on verrait un
peu plus marine le pen à l'assemblée ça
ne voudraient s'impliquer dans la vie
parlementaire parce que là il est parti
quand même dû du quart de députés les
moins actifs et puis ensuite quand on a
un groupe on excusez-moi de pour le
micro ça rapporte de l'argent c'est à
dire qu'à partir de quinze députés
chaque député rapport
aux trente sept mille euros par an donc
imaginer marine le pen qui a des
objectifs assez élevés elle prétend
avoir 160 depuis deux ans ça lui ferait
un un bonus par rapport à la nature
présente donc des millions d'ailleurs
j'ai fait le calcul
pas désagréable non plus donc alors
pourquoi ne fait-elle pas alliance avec
eric zemmour les alliances et ce qui
permet de couvrir à télévisé a que des
histoires dessous non plus dans quel
intérêt de de s'allier avec eric zemmour
franchement 1 les médias se sont
passionnés pour zemmour pendant la
campagne résultat il a fait 7 % marine
le pen la débandade avancé dans plus de
90% les circonscriptions donc en fête et
moore c'est quand même un caillou dans
sa chaussure en qu'est ce que vous
faites quand vous avez un kiteboat
chaussures vous essayer en tout cas de
l'enlever donc c'est ce qu'ils font est
reine et jordan bardel a été envoyé en
mission dans la circonscription de
zemmour la quatrième du var bas pour lui
savonner la planche explications je me
permets de vous rappeler que la
circonscription dans laquelle est
candidat et règlements que je ne peux
pas citer pour des raisons et voilà nous
avons fait 57 % des voix au second tour
l'élection présidentielle donc c'est
bien normal que nous ayons un candidat
qui était candidat à la dernière fois
qui est qui est un candidat comme
beaucoup de candidats du r n est lui
implanter reconnu qui travaillent le
terrain depuis des années donc eric
zemmour c'est pas dieu quand ils
arrivent quelque part la mère ne s'ouvre
pas non parce qu'en attendant oui je
voulais dire rires oui c'est vrai
en attendant le leader de l'opposition
c'est pas le pen c'est mélenchon vous
savez ce que ce qu'on disait la nature a
horreur du vide me suis renseigné
aristote qui disait ça je pense qu'il
s'est trompé à l'époque mais en tout cas
les médias c'est pareil ils ont horreur
du vide donc forcément quand macro ont
été réélus c'était prévu depuis
longtemps
qu'est-ce qu'on allait raconter
heureusement mélenchon arrive avec une
histoire qu'ils aient en main de lui élu
premier ministre élu résultat on ne
parlait que de ça à regarder france
inter première radio de france 75% du
temps d'antenne pour les interviews
politiques c'était le nu pèse donc comme
il ya un équipe de temps de parole
maintenant il faut rattraper avec marine
le pen qu'elle était sur rtl dimanche
elle était ce matin sur france 2 elle a
fait un déplacement dans l'oise dont je
pense qu'on va la voir dans tous les jt
ce smartphone commencent à apparaître
faire pression quelles sont ses
arguments dans cette campagne zorglub en
fait c'est pas une intello non plus
marine le pen théorise pas l'union des
droites qu'américains moore pas une
apparatchik comme mélenchon qui est
capable de faire des cavalières de
partie pour faire des alliances est
lambron c'est simplement la réalité
c'est l'actu en fait puisque la réalité
c'est la tutelle qu'elle est présente et
qui lui sert pour convaincre là
franchement il ya un boulevard pour elle
le stade de france à a un boulevard
c'est gravissime les faits sont
gravissimes et le mensonge du ministre
est gravissime en réalité la france a
donné le spectacle de ce qu'elle est en
train de devenir c'est à dire une zone
de non-droit général et ce sous la
pression d'une immigration anarchique et
d'une délinquance qui est hors contrôle
donc elle a dit gravissime pour le stade
de france donc maintenant on parle de
l'embargo sur le pétrole russe donc là
on touche au pouvoir d'achat c'est
vraiment son grand truc qu'est ce
qu'elle va dire on va dire désastreux on
va dire affreux programmatique quelqu'un
a une idée ou pas alès répondre cette
décision va avoir des conséquences
cataclysmiques sur le pouvoir d'achat
des français
voilà ça va être dramatique ce choix là
c'est le choix du sacrifice du pouvoir
d'achat des français - pardon mais je
pense encore une fois au pouvoir d'achat
des français
cataclysmique vous l'aviez pas sûr non
envoyé moi je trouve que ça ne va pas si
mal finalement pour marine le pen en
ligne depuis 20 ans dit oh là là mais
c'est la femme marine le pen c'est la
fin la famille le pen c'est la fin du
racing est plutôt en forme et est bien
parti personnellement je m'inquiète pas
pour elle si j'avais de l'affection pour
son égard eh bien écoutez merci nous
avons planté le décor merci pour ce
papier ce billet stéphane on va tout de
suite voilà solliciter nos experts vols
low bâchée c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup
dit que marine le pen manqué d'ambition
dans cette campagne s'est éclipsé
pendant quinze jours juste après sa
défaite à la présidentielle
jean-luc mélenchon très clairement été à
l'offensive est ce que vous voyez les
choses comme ça
d'ambition peut-être pas en tout cas
elle peut être
perçue comme réaliste et elle a pris
c'est sur deux semaines de vacances tout
son entourage constate en tout cas qui
sont fait doubler par mélenchon assez
vite en fait puisque lui a eu deux
semaines de l'entre-deux tours pour ça
en coulisses et reconnaît collet ont
collé scirocco
comment ils essaient d'expliquer ce
retard est en tout cas ne pas montrer
que c'est un retard grave ils disent que
le rectorat est un exemple qui rentre
tard aussi dans la campagne j'ai
vraiment autour de semaine douze jours
avant le premier tour pour ça qu'ils
accélèrent
marine le pen elle a toujours eu ce côté
un peu diesel en fait elle refait ce qui
s'est passé pendant la présidentielle à
l'échelle des initiatives sur un temps
beaucoup plus court une campagne de
terrain sous les radars et monte en
puissance on veut la gagner cette
campagne en tout cas de maximiser ses
être sûr d'avoir un groupe ça c'est le
dit clairement
elle veut pas sûr vendre quelque chose
qu'elle ne veut peut pas vendre c'est ce
qu'elle dit
pourquoi ça c'est au nom de quoi d'une
stratégie du il ya une part de la
franchise de mystère parce que je pense
qu'elle voulait pas jouer le troisième
tour en réalité c'est à dire qu'elle
voulait pas dire que votre première
ministre alors que son réel objectif
c'est de présidence de la république
c'est la présence de république du coup
c'était un petit peu d'admettre qu'à
l'ailé toujours perdre être premier
ministre et un coup d'essai
reconnaissent que jean luc mélenchon a
réussi un coup puisque ces magistrats
cerveau politique parce qu'il n'avait
jamais il n'avait pas vu venir il
pensait que la gauche terrasse et il ya
eu cette remonte ada qui a été chroniqué
dans les médias le soir du premier tour
il avait un peu fait peur et qu'ils
avaient beaucoup énervé d'ailleurs par
rapport
à la narration médiatique qui a eu lieu
au lendemain du premier tour en estimant
qu'on allait passer parler des bons
sondages de marine le pen notamment le
fameux 49 51 % de l'ifop le soir du
premier tour qui leur permettait de le
redire il était au bord la victoire et
qu'ils pouvaient gagner
et du coup ils pensaient réellement la
gauche terrassé et ça c'est ce qu'a fait
mélenchon ça rentre pas du tout dans
leur narratif marine le pen elle a un
clivage qui a vu en salle et depuis
qu'elle est à la tête du front et du rnc
le clivage entre les mondialistes et les
nationaux entre elles emmanuel macron
donc un troisième bloc salle arthur
baisse d'abord ce clivage
pascal perrineau merci pour ces
coulisses je reviens vers vous tôt dans
un instant au fond est là les terres
d'élection 150 circonscriptions en tête
c'est pas rien elle a fait plus de
13 millions de voix au deuxième tour
c'est pas rien et pourtant c'est quoi
c'est cette année mode de scrutin qui
fait qu'elle ne pourra pas être la
première force d'opposition pour nous et
19 juin prochains en termes territoriale
l'implantation de marine le pen est tout
à fait impressionnante vous savez quand
vous prenez les 35000 communes au second
tour marine le pen gagne dans beaucoup
plus de communes parce qu'on a un
émiettement du tissu communal qu
emmanuel macron ce qui veut dire
l'ampleur de la pénétration voyait dans
ces communes rurales dans ces communes
ruben
nord est et sud est il ya là quelque
chose en effet qui est tout à fait tout
à fait impressionnant cependant si vous
voulez le rassemblement national qu'est
ce que c'est une puissance électorale
évidente 13 millions
42 % des suffrages exprimés au second
tour c'est tout même pas n'importe quoi
mais c'est une puissance solitaire le
mode de scrutin majoritaire à deux tours
même quand vous êtes un parti puissant
aussi c'était le cas du parti communiste
par exemple au début de la vème
république si vous n'avez pas d'alliés
qui alimente une dynamique majoritaire
pour le second tour eh bien oui vous
pouvez avoir un groupe elle aura un
groupe elle aura peut-être un groupe
plus confortable qu'on ne le dit
elle peut avoir un groupe qui tourne aux
alentours de 50 députés un voyez ça peut
aller entre 25 et 50 députés à peu près
la halle et serait déjà ce qui serait
déjà mme boutin fouet avec ce mode de
scrutin référence que la dernière fois
et inscrit que le fn avait eu un groupe
c'était dans le cadre de la
proportionnelle là ça serait dans le
cadre du magistrat
1986 c'est ce serait dans le cadre du
majoritaire ça voudrait dire que voilà
ça y est le front national a une
capacité à casser le plaçons 2 le
plafond de verre comme on dit dans les
30 40 circonscriptions mais voyez que
dans l'entre-deux-tours ils pourront
faire elle dit voilà par exemple nous
arrivait en tête dans 150
circonscriptions oui mais c'est pas au
majoritaire à un tour nelly les les
députés sitôt majoritaire à deux tours
déjà si on passe le premier tour il y
aura beaucoup beaucoup de duels c'est ça
très peu de triangulaires et dans un
duel il ya toujours ce front républicain
qui va jouer c'est un dieu la pédagogie
il faut les réserves sont valeureux
certainement les réserves du modeste des
électeurs de reconquête de quelques
souverainistes de droite mais ça n'ira
pas au delà puisqu'on sait très bien que
même l'électorat de la droite de
gouvernement dans un second tour il sera
plus tenté par un candidat par exemple
macro nice tout un candidat macro nist
horizon que par un candidat ou une
candidate et rennes et dans un cadre du
lrn mélenchon
s'il peut se passer ça a existé bien sûr
ça peut exister et ils peuvent trouver
là une marge de manoeuvre ils peuvent
prétendre à ce moment là fédérer on
parle du front républicain mais là y
aura un autre type de front c'est le
front anti gauche extrême et certains
candidats est un candidat de la france à
soubise alors stéphane zumsteeg il faut
s'y font c'est un second temps il faut
mieux mobiliser si vous n'avez pas assez
d'électeurs on n'a aucune chance de
passer le deuxième tour où en sont les
électeurs de marine le pen on dit
beaucoup que les législatives sont
délaissés par les jeunes et par les
classes populaires c'est le prince et
son électorat le principal enjeu à court
terme en tout cas le principal enjeu
électoral c'est évidemment de garder
mobiliser les les 24 % de français qui
ont voté pour elle au premier tour parce
qu'on parle beaucoup du second tome ce
qui compte avant tout dans cette logique
des législatives c'est très un très bon
score au premier tour pour se qualifier
au niveau de la participation et en
particulier de son électorat tout ce que
nous montre les différentes enquêtes qui
sont publiés là c'est que l'abstention
va être au moins aussi forte qu'il ya
cinq ans pour mémoire pour rappel il ya
cinq ans 51% des français s'étaient
abstenus au premier tour des élections
législatives aujourd'hui on est à un
niveau de 53 54% ce qui n'est pas une
bonne nouvelle pour le rassemblement
national parce que effectivement
traditionnellement ce sont les jeunes et
les milieux populaires qui sont des plus
abstentionniste surtout pour les
scrutins qui peuvent être jugés
secondaires je ne dis pas que les
législatives sont un scrutin secondaire
et pour une partie de l'électorat en
tout cas pour la partie qui parfois
s'abstient partent parfois participent
et bien dégustatif ne sont pas forcément
des élections qui comptait c'était une
assez mauvaise nouvelle pour le
rassemblement national parce que si son
électorat n'est pas au rendez vous
de la participation
les résultats du récent langues
nationales risquent d'être risque d'être
décevant je vous donne juste quelques
chiffres il ya cinq ans marine le pen
obtient 21 % au premier tour mais ces
candidats n'obtient que 13 % lors du
premier tour des élections
huit élus cette fois ci pour l'instant
ça a l'air de tenir ces territoires a
l'air de tenir à l'air de vouloir aller
participer
le pen a fait 24 % ont sonné à peu près
des intentions de vote aux alentours de
20% pour ces candidats dont briques la
déperdition et on va regarder d'ailleurs
un magistrat steria qui s'affiche c'est
un sondage vous vous demandez si les
candidats se présentaient dans votre
circonscription pour lequel il y aurait
le plus de chances que vous votiez pour
pour lui au premier tour laine épaisse
27% et le candidat soutenu par emmanuel
macron majorité présidentielle 28 et
rassemblement national 21 oui donc les
deux principales foires sont au coude à
coude mais malgré ce 21 % derrière les
projections que l'on a que l'on a
préparé que l'on a calculé bien de tous
sans résultat qui sera décevant pour le
rassemblement national parce que même
avec 21% des voix pour l'instant si tu
ça va évoluer dans les dix jours qui
viennent évidemment une fourchette de 20
à 40 sièges saint-siège oui c'est très
peu par rapport aux 577
députés qui vont être élus tout ça mais
pascal perrineau l'a dit parce que les
élections digital ils sont un scrutin
terrible pour le rassemblement national
c'est la conjonction de toutes les
facteurs de tous ces handicaps qui se
conjuguent un moment donné qui font que
quel que soit son niveau en voix à
l'échelle nationale eh bien les
résultats en sièges ne sont pour la
plupart du temps très décevant voire
très bon alors on a essayé de prendre la
température du terrain puis je vous
redonne la parole juste après comment
elle se passe cette campagne reportage
de clément perreault qui s'est rendu en
gironde dans une circonscription où
marine le pen est arrivée largement en
tête regarde
c'est un petit séisme politique qui a
secoué la gironde dans la 11e
circonscription qui regroupe l'ail et
ses alentours marine le pen a fait 58 %
au second tour de la présidentielle dans
le village de gauriac edwige dias la
candidate et rennes aux législatives la
fiche de souris
corbara merci d'être là elle organise
une réunion publique
la mobilisation est très importante
surtout dans une législative où on sait
que malheureusement il ya beaucoup
d'abstention donc moi en fait mon
objectif c'est que y ait le moins
d'abstention des électeurs et rennes
possible à 34 ans edwige diaz est une
figure montante du parti elle était
porte-parole de la campagne de marine le
pen la gironde n'a jamais eu de meilleur
ni de députés est reine cette
circonscription serait une prise de
choix qui on perd cette circonscription
si on la gagne pas eh bien elle va être
saccagée dans notre territoire on a
quand même beaucoup souffert de beaucoup
de choses des explications des services
publics donc perdre du pouvoir d'achat
et caetera et donc on ne peut pas donner
les pleins pouvoirs un accroc
face à ce discours la députée sortante
candidate à sa réélection a choisi de
prendre le contre-pied c'est en combi
volkswagen que veronica merrer
sillonnent la circonscription l'idée est
de donner une image plus positive du
territoire qu'on sort de la crise on est
en pleine guerre je trouvais intéressant
de pouvoir utiliser un combi parce que
c'est cool c'est baba cool et il permet
de la sympathie tout simplement voix
face à la menace est reine veronica
merrer met en avant le bilan de la
majorité oui il ya eu les gilet jaune
ben oui effectivement il ya eu la
contestation oui a eu la colère oui
c'est vrai que ça existe mais il n'ya
pas que ça il ya aussi des choses qui
fonctionnent moi ici j'ai des
entreprises qui viennent s'installer sur
ce territoire et on a des pôles de santé
pluridisciplinaires avec des médecins
avaient des infirmières et je trouve moi
personnellement qu'on n'en parle pas
suffisamment face à ce duel annoncé
mathieu caillaud de l'union des gauches
espère créer la surprise et là un coup
de génie mélenchon en disant haut à la
fin du premier tour qu'il allait être
premier ministre parce qu'il a
ringardisé le débat entre mâcon et le
pen à droite la candidate heller voit
plus dans la percée du r'n l'expression
d'une colère qu un véritable vote
d'adhésion quelles sont les propositions
des races un virage très concrètement
pour la circonscription je les attends
si c'est le repli sur soi la fermeture
des frontières qu'est-ce qu'on va dire à
nos vignerons ceux qui ceux qui
exportent je pense que les gens
n'adhèrent pas
à ces valeurs là huit autres candidats
sont en lice pour cette 11e
circonscription de giroud
palau bachet la gironde est devenue une
terre de conquête devenu une terre de
conquête contre toute attente notamment
grâce au travail de la personne qu'on a
vu à la télévision edwige diaz qui a
mené la tête de liste aux régionales qui
a fait un travail depuis dix ans sur ce
territoire là alors à son échelle parce
qu'elles et ils sont pas très nombreux
et rennes ils ont toujours un problème
de militantisme c'est un parti car
beaucoup de problèmes militantisme il ya
plus beaucoup de militants il ya encore
quelques cadres qui travaillent le
terrain c'est elle essayait d'appliquer
la recette de marine le pen dans le nord
c'est à dire de récupérer les voix de
gauche des voix de gens qui subissent le
déclassement social la crise économique
qui ont souvent sûrement été gilet jaune
en 2019 fin 2018 ce début 2019 voilà
donc c'est il y a plein territoire comme
ça qu'ils sont en train de devenir des
territoires j'en ai dit mariniste je
sais pas vraiment des territoires
frontiste contrairement à la paca on
peut parler aussi la circonscription se
présente jean michel blanquer la loire
est voilà loiret où le candidat
et rennes s'est dit bien ce n'est pas
très longtemps pour y faire ça compense
en face à jean-michel blanquer
espoirs
modèle tinsel ministre il ya un modèle
qui essaie d'être épique et à petite
échelle pas forcément de manière très
organisée mais de d'aller chercher des
voix le web populaires alors c'est
intéressant parce que on se dit pareil
la progression progression qui on tombe
toujours sur cette question du mode de
scrutin elle est portée aussi par par
l'actualité le pouvoir d'achat tel
numéro un des français ont tout tous les
partis le disent ils ne parlent que de
ça les français est-ce que ça ça peut
lui permettre quand même de gagner
quelques points des sites latif de
mobiliser ça lui permettra peut-être
d'éviter le scénario 2017 ou en effet on
avait l'impression que le rassemblement
national
voilà connaissez une érosion inévitable
là on a l'impression les premiers
sondages sur offre politique réelle dans
chacune des circonscriptions sont faits
et on a l'impression d'un arn qui tient
mieux et en effet la conjoncture le
tollé du le taux d'inflation annoncé les
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat une grogne
qui continue être là regardez toutes les
enquêtes
après les élections sur le bout des
doigts pour ça arrivera si cela arrive
d'ailleurs après les élections donc il y
à un contexte qui peut être favorable
mais il restera une équation politique
du mode de scrutin stéphane zumsteeg
hausse et le pouvoir d'achat la qui est
encore en tête des priorités ya aucun
doute là dessus oui absolument c'est la
preuve la thématique qui écrase la
campagne même s'il ya le stade de france
la faire à damien abad tout ça c'est
même si haut si on parle davantage
d'éducation de santé d'écologie
notamment depuis le virage comment
l'appeler écologistes ou social de
d'emmanuel macron dans
l'entre-deux-tours ce sont aussi des
thématiques qui sont comme un petit peu
plus présente mais c'est vrai que c'est
le pouvoir d'achat et les exemples que
vous donniez de ces circonscriptions où
on a enregistré une fois paupérise
paupérisation de la population sont des
vrais territoire des nouveaux
territoires de conquête du r n on a
beaucoup parlé tout à l'heure de
d'éventuels duels avec la venue des sous
avec la majorité présidentielle moi je
pense quand même que les principaux
territoires de conquête de sièges pour
leur assemblée nationale se situe
toujours dans l'est de la france pas que
le nord-est dans l'est de la france
c'est à dire il faut pas oublier qu'il
ya quand même 125 députés de droite
classique à l'air udi comme il n'y aura
pas de triangulaire comme il n'y aura
que deux qualifiés pour le second tour
la droite pourrait être éliminée au
premier tour dans des circonscriptions
de droite aujourd'hui donc à ce que
compte tenu de la radicalisation d'une
partie de cet électorat souvent dans des
zones rurales donc des réserves qui
viendrait peut-être de la droite c'est
ce que vous dites des réserves qui
donnerait des circonscriptions de duane
pas forcément de l'électorat de droite
mais mais c'était dans des
circonscriptions message elle rêve des
voix de droite
si le fn progresse et va jusqu'à vingt
trente quarante cinquante députés je
pense que ce sera plus dense est parti
de la france à la basse et vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que ce n'était pas
vraiment un parti de militants le
rassemblement national est ce que c'est
un parti qui s'est professionnalisé qui
peut se permettre de présenter
maintenant plus de 500 candidats
compétents capables de défendre un
programme des yeux quelques déconvenues
quand même un qui ont fait voilà pas mal
le commentaire des candidats qui
perdaient leurs moyens dans des villes à
la grande question c'est est-ce que
c'est l'exception est ce que c'est la
règle ce genre de candidat
c'est plutôt la règle
le front national par le arn a toujours
un problème de formation de cadres sais
pas disons absolument pas travailler sur
ce sujet là depuis 2010 est parce qu il
ya eu la défaite cinglante en fait qui a
perturbé le système avec qui a perturbé
la famille politique il eu des départs
comme un maréchal ferrant flipo faut
voir ça sur le long terme il eu des
déconvenues
aux municipales aux régionales dont il
ya au moins des looks prévu donc moins
deux personnes et de personnels formés
politiquement sur le terrain
donc non il ya des il ya des problèmes
de ressources humaines nous offrons
ce qui change par rapport à 2010 est
c'est que cette fois-ci marine a
plutôt orienté ses proches ou plutôt des
gens compétents de l'aude est proche car
ils sont gagnables
des gens qui peuvent devenir compétents
une fois élu je pense à caroline
parmentier qui est son attachée de
presse qui se présentent à béthune alors
que c'est une personne qui vit plutôt
dans l'ouest parisien après son dd sur
le parachutage arrive dans toutes les
formations politiques mais là on voit
bien que au delà du groupe marie le pen
avait surtout avoir les députés qu'elle
veut ouais elle a souffert aussi quand
même j'imagine des transferts vers eric
zemmour elle perd aussi des des bons
candidats potentiels non elle vous notre
dira jamais ça 2 en public et en privé
non ce qui comment elle voit les
défections vers les xénons elle estime
que ce sont des gens qui de toute
manière de re plus à plus leur place
dans la nouvelle formation politique
qu'elle veut elle avait d'autres projets
déjà voilà c'est il y avait d'autres
différences
jamais envisagé je pense qu'elle n'a
jamais pensé pourquoi parce que c'est la
verrière manque de sens politique d'hier
ça peut être perçu comme un manque de
sens politique mais la réalité c'est que
elle estime qu eric zemmour et
d'extrême-droite c'est ça en fait le
principaux points de friction c'est
qu'elle elle estime qu'elle ne l'est pas
donc cessons c'est sa vision des choses
ans et elle estime qu'un règlement et
d'extrême droite donc c'est maigret
parce qu'elle a déjà vécu
merci
toute cette partie identitaire laissant
droite très catholique très identitaire
très réactionnaire très grand stratège
et conditionne philippe olivier sur son
par son parcours
et passez donc du magret tisme un peu du
de ce côté soul sur l'extrême droite lui
dit j'ai compris pourquoi on avait perdu
pascal perrineau au fond ce serait plus
par positionnement profondément cohérent
idéologique que cette alliance ne serait
pas possible vous y croyez vous j'ai
quand même une querelle personnelle tout
simplement il a humilié jeanne critiquer
je ne crois pas et là regardez
attentivement d'abord les raisons de
l'échec de son père souvenez-nous en
2002 il sélectionne il est sélectionné 7
pour le second tour mais il est
incapable d'en d'entraîner une dynamique
elle elle est capable d'entraîner une
dynamique en 2010 est elle a été capable
d'entraîner une dynamique qui n'est pas
victorieusement faut tout de même en
2022 donc elle veut absolument élargir
le cercle des convaincus et et je crois
qu'elle est beaucoup plus maintenant
elle se dit au fond en france et
ailleurs contre la globalisation dans la
mobilisation des couches populaires il y
un espace pour des forces nationales et
populisme le
rassemblement national aujourd'hui et un
national populisme plus qu'une extrême
droite classique en revanche eric
zemmour est venu y est resté
véritablement sur ce créneau eux d'une
extrême droite au fond pour aller vite
héritière d'une droite mots d'une
extrême droite maurrassienne voyez c'est
en effet c'est différent on dit ya des
droits qu'il ya des gauches il ya des
extraits ce que les électeurs on va dire
de la droite de la droite et de
l'extrême droite mais terre ça comme ça
qu'on prenne ça où est-ce qu'au fond
pour eux l'alliance qui est cohérent de
zemmour et le pen va de soi
traditionnement déjà les gens qui votent
pour l'ex pour le reste pour le front
national pour leur assemblée nationale
sont toujours assez disciplinés et
suivre les consignes en tout cas suivre
les décisions pas vraiment des consignes
m'excuse les décisions qui sont prises
par les chefs de parti en l'occurrence
par marine le pen oui si vous 4
les aurait évidemment beaucoup aimé qui
est une alliance pour que survive
l'expérience de reconquête ce qui n'est
évidemment pas sûr aujourd'hui on sait
pas de quoi sera fait le lendemain pour
la formation d'eric zemmour mais vont
parler totale de sens politique moi je
pense qu'elle n'a pas du tout manqué de
sens politique en refusant l'alliance la
pêche aux élus très chaud à l'automne
dernier des enquêtes d'opinion
montraient et mouret le pen au coude à
coude c'était une catastrophe pour l
faim pendant cinq ans elle avait été
annoncée au second tour et c'était d'un
coup ce n'était en quelques semaines ce
n'était plus le cas là l'objectif pour
elle et ça s'est passé comme ça d'
élections présidentielles c'est
d'essayer de tuer définitivement ce
mouvement qui représente un vrai danger
pour pour le rassemblement national
qu'est ce que ça va coûter ce refus
d'alliance au récent rassemblement
national peut-être quelques sièges 5 6
peut-être dix au maximum dans le sud de
la france n'a rien ce n'est pas rien
mais me vois se passer de cinq à dix
députés que d'avoir face à soi une
formation avec eric zemmour qui
passerait peut-être un quart ou un tiers
de ce vote de ce vote d'idées dit
d'extrême droite donc moi je pense que
c'est une super du tout dans la poudre à
une paix ne suis pas dans le combat et
nos peines mais je pense que l'inde a
pris la bonne décision en terme de
cynisme et de réalisme me plaire pour
conclure ce débat va se projeter paloma
chez vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure
qu'elle avait des ambitions un peu plus
grande juste après la présidentielle
jusqu'à 150 députés ça sera pas
forcément ça je crois qu'on a bien
compris ça et après qu'est ce qu'elle
veut qu est ce qu elle cherchait ce
qu'elle est prête à avoir un successeur
est ce qu'elle est prête à faire grandir
une génération et est ce qu'elle est
prête à abandonner comme elles semblent
le dire
alors moi je fais partie des gens qui ne
pensent pas qu'il va abandonner 2027 il
ya plusieurs raisons c'est que elle veut
pas reprendre le parti pourquoi je pars
pour le parti c'est parce qu'il a
constaté que pendant la campagne elle
avait quitté la prison du parti laisser
la charge alors john baird et là ça lui
a beaucoup plu et cela permet de mener
la campagne qu'elle voulait mais elle
n'a pas gagné c'est du coup prendre la
présidence d'un groupe avec les députés
qu'elle a choisi dans l'âme hier
circonscription de france du r n va lui
permet de constituer ce qu'on peut dire
comme étant un contre parti ou un parti
bis pour pouvoir continuer à travailler
son programme à travailler
électoralement à former une nouvelle
génération d'élus
à l'assemblée nationale à voir dès le
financement de groupes n'ont qu'un
secrétaire général du groupe dont tous a
par la suite cédé base les mêmes bases
que corrélation les mêmes bases que
mélenchon 2017 pour pour être candidate
potentielle mot le mot de la fin pascal
perrineau dans ce duel qu'elle voudrait
éviter avec jean luc mélenchon lui aussi
va marquer des points à l'assemblée il
va de toute façon faire grandir son
groupe et proposer des députés qui
seront très fort mais pour 2027 s'est
enfoncée alors rendez vous commun mais
oui mais mélenchon n'a pas l'âge de
marine le pen marine le pen a gênés
rationnellement plus d'avenir que jean
luc mélenchon faut pas l'oublier et le
prochain opposant si marine le pen se
maintient le prochain opposant ne sera
plus emmanuel macron donc il y à là
plusieurs éléments ont dit vous voulez
qui rend complètement incertain et il
rend des différends liés à un c est là
la scène techno laisse sceptique sur
l'idée que voilà ce serait la fin de
carrière de marina bay eh bien on verra
tout cela merci beaucoup merci
infiniment pour vos analyses et d'être
venu sur le plateau
décrypter la stratégie officielle et
officieuse de marine le pen aurait à
présent accueillir notre grand témoin
son histoire est digne d'un roman de
john le carré il est entré la même année
que vladimir poutine à l'école d'espions
russes de moscou agent du kgb il a
infiltré la france et il a même été
admis à l'ena avant de demander l'asile
politique dans notre pays aujourd'hui il
témoigne de son parcours hors norme de
ce qu'il a compris aussi du maître du
kremlin on a plein de questions à poser
à sergueï chertov comme les skis ce
sujet signé clément méric
[Musique]
si on vous invite sergueï mironov c'est
d'abord parce que votre histoire facile
adolescents passés par les jeunesses
communistes soviétiques vous avez été
espion pour le kgb avant de vous
réfugier en france mais on vous invite
aussi parce que vous avez croisé la
route de vladimir poutine à plusieurs
reprises notamment en 1981 vous étiez
alors un jeune étudiant de 19 ans dans
le bureau il y avait un petit bonhomme
tout petit bonhomme en costume gris qui
m'a mis dans une volga noir avec un
gyrophare
pendant deux heures c'est poutine qui
vous interrogeait et
en fait on sentait que le pouvoir de
manipuler les gens le pouvoir de on met
la pression saluer faisait vraiment
vraiment plaisir sur votre cv sergueï
mironov difficile de s'y retrouver car
pour mener à bien vos activités
d'espionnage vous avez multiplié les
couvertures journaliste animateur télé
consultant international et même
traducteur aux jo d'albertville
aujourd'hui vous publié de livre
l'engrenage vous y décrypter ce qui a
poussé vladimir poutine a déclenché la
guerre en ukraine et l'éclaireur vous y
raconter votre histoire celle d'un
espion infiltré en france comme jeune
journaliste un journaliste dont nous
avons retrouvé la trace sergueï chertov
vous êtes présentateur à la télévision
de moscou et vous faites partie du jury
pour jour pour ce festival de descente
de rivière c'était en 1989 en pleine
chute du mur de berlin hier mais on
pourrait peut-être avoir votre avis
votre réaction sur les événements qui se
passe en ce moment en allemagne je suis
un peu étonné de la vitesse avec les
avec laquelle les événements se
déroulent à nana vous avez envie que ça
bouge un peu plus vite également en
union soviétique
oui oui pourquoi pas
ce oui est-il un mensonge de plus de l'
agent du kgb ou alors l'espoir sincère
d'un jeune russe séduit par l'occident
avec vous impossible de le savoir votre
principal fait d'armes est d'avoir
intégré l'ena sur recommandation d'une
certaine valérie pécresse
votre mission était alors de récolter un
maximum d'informations sur vos camarades
de promo appelé à un brillant admis mais
votre vie est tellement riche en
rebondissements qu'une question nous
brûle les lèvres sergueï mironov comment
savoir si tout cela est bien vérité
bonsoir sergueï mironov et merci
infiniment d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors on va parler de votre
livre dans un instant mais est-ce que
tout est vrai dans votre histoire vous
écoutez vrai tout est vrai mais ça me
fait ça me fait vraiment chaud au coeur
parce que c'est la première fois que je
revois si ces images des festivals de
films de descente de rivière
je suis ce qu'on vous dit j'aimerais
bien voir les choses évoluer en union
soviétique c'est incroyable ouais et
qu'est ce que vous avez fait alors
pendant ces années pendant ces années là
j'ai agi travailler pour m'installer en
france pour ma fille très dans votre
pays voilà donc là c'était deux ans
avant lennar ce sont les services russes
qui vous ont permis d'apprendre le
français c'est ça
c'est pas le service d'espionnage
puisque le français je n'ai appris home
demo qui est l'institut des relations
internationales de moscou une guitare
l'espionnage je vais apprendre
l'espagnol mais j'aimais pas trop
l'amérique latine dans laquelle le kgb
me poussez donc en fait j'ai réussi à
contourner trucs pour revenir vers la
france mais vous vous imaginez bien que
c'est extrêmement compliqué de se
figurer la réalité de votre histoire
parce que vous avez fait cette école
d'espions à moscou la grande école
andropov c'est ça ensuite vous êtes venu
en france infiltrer et puis ensuite vous
avez vous lu au fond quitté
j'ai quitté la cage et mais les années
90 mais on quitte pas comme ça c'est
seulement on quitte c'est pas une
démission si c'est une des missions vous
savez pourquoi c'était c'était la seule
époque historiquement où c'était
possible d'habitude on ne quitte pas
avant on ne quittez pas maintenant on ne
quitte pas mais il y avait trois années
de 1991 à 1993 ou le kgb avait peur et
ils avaient peur que ça se passe
exactement pour que pour la stasi en
herbert en excès revers en fait il avait
peur pour eux parce qu'ils ont fait à un
putsch contre gorbatchev en août 1991 et
donc précieux s'est vengé sur le kgb il
a dissout et là vous lui même dissoudre
le parti communiste et puis au mois de
décembre en pleine figure au camarade
gorbatchev c'est l'union soviétique a
cessé d'exister et à cette époque là le
kgb avait tellement la trouille qui
laissait partir tout le monde ces partis
pourtant pourtant il ya eu le fsb assez
vite après tout à fait alors expliquez
moi une chose on a compris en gros vous
avez
quittez vous avez aussi essayer de faire
toute la transparence sur votre histoire
vous avez assumé vous avez même clamé
que vous étiez un espion russe il a
fallu d'ailleurs que vous ayez des
preuves de cela c'était compliqué parce
qu'il vous fallait votre diplôme de
l'école c'est ça c'est en réalité quand
je vous protéger il fallait le dire en
fait c'est ça c'est ça ça veut dire que
à partir de 1993 lorsque primakov est
revenu au svr et l'a compris que s'est
terminée la peau de petite pause et est
terminé maintenant on peut recommencer à
reconstruire un vrai service
d'espionnage et donc elle a voulu
récupérer tout le monde et en 1995 on
m'a recontacté du service m'a recontacté
mais je voulais plus parce que je me
suis dit c'est une seule fois cas où ça
se passe comme ça et ils ont commencé à
faire pression sur moi je possédais des
secrets n'est d'ailleurs assez assez
important à cette époque là est la seule
façon de mettre croix sur ce passé était
de révéler les gens comme moi je pouvais
le pas le dire la seule façon c'était de
faire le procès pour ce diplôme j'en ai
rien à voir avec face
se dit que je n'avais pas besoin de 100
diplômés on va pas raconter toute
l'histoire c'est que voilà vous avez
fini pas sans avoir le diplôme avoir des
preuves absolues des mails qui
témoignent mieux mieux que ça c'est un
gilet papier les lettres en papier g11
les trois premiers du service
d'espionnage qui reconnaît mon
appartenance et d'une et 2,2 g 4
décision de justice je suis passé
jusqu'à la cour suprême qui à chaque
fois me disais non on va pas vous donner
votre diplôme mais il ya une décision du
6 qui disaient oui on reconnaît qu aux
états nations oui on reconnaît que vous
à perdre et aussi voilà d'être protégé
et puis d'obtenir au début des années
2000 l'asile politique vous êtes réfugié
politique dans notre pays c'est ça c'est
ça je suis je suis venu en 2000 2001
parce qu'en début 2001 j'ai subi un
petit empoisonnement je suis je suis pas
mort et donc j'ai compris que c'était à
mon avis c'était un avertissement
peut-être et j'ai compris que il fallait
il fallait quitter le pays des
frontières était été ouverte donc j'en
ai profité et en 2002 j'ai déposé
d'asile mais bien évidemment vous
imaginez un espion qui a infiltré lennar
puis demande d'asile en france
mais c'est intéressant va on va
justement puisque vous nous pas d'un
petit empoisonnement vont revenir tout
de suite à vladimir poutine ça c'est
l'engrenage ya ce livre personnel et
puis sodie filiale d'un michel qui
raconte au fond qui est poutine vous
l'avez rencontré quatre fois entre les
années 80 et 90 vous décrivez un homme
au fond qui a raté sa carrière d'espion
médiocre complexé maladroit et vous
allez même comparé à adolf hitler
peintre raté humilié par la défaite
allemande en 1918 pas si c'est pas moi
c'est l'histoire qui a qui ne fait c'est
ainsi parallèle parce que justement rang
pour pour le ratage de carrière ça c'est
documenté ce footing qui est qui lui
même a raconté d'ailleurs je me suis
demandé à quoi il pensait en 2000 quand
il publier son premier livre
autobiographique avant de devenir le
président il a raconté que en 1984 il a
été envoyé à moscou et en 85 il est
revenu en grâce si les revenus années
grâce c'est que on l'a pas gardé il ya
ces niveaux donc il a raté la carrière
d'espion pas ce qu'est ce qu'il a fait
en rdr c'est pas une carrière d'espion
il habitait dans dans l'immeuble où
c'était marqué choisi il avait lac la
carte d'identité de la stasi toute la
ville connaissait tout ça est donc en
fait il était officier de liaison en
herbert et puis après on dit oui il est
petit oui il est insignifiant oui il est
gris mais il est discipliné sauf que il
est en retard partout où il passe elle
est très embêté il est très jeune il est
très ambitieux mais ils le cachent ils
le cachent et qu'à chaque fois on
lorsqu'on lui proposer une promotion il
disait n'honore je ne veux pas et vous
imaginez que la personne qui refuse les
systématiquement les promotions passé
elles concourront qu'on pousse et
surtout s'il ya la famille eltsine a
compris que cet homme pouvait leur
rendre service et sont
royalement royalement trompé alors tout
le monde essaye de savoir ce qu'elle a
dans la tête depuis le 24 février le
déclenchement de la guerre aujourd'hui
il est complètement cloître et c'est ça
il enfermé au kremlin ou part de bon
coeur on dit qu'il est reclus
paranoïaque vous dites même vous qu'il
utiliserait des sosies dans certaines
manifestations ça c'est vrai on peut
l'affirmer où c'est une intuition on
peut pas l'affirmer mais moi j'ai lu des
reportages
d'investigation qui disait en fait ils
prenaient toutes les photos de poutine
il superpose et ses photos ils ont
trouvé que il ya trois personnes qui
n'ont pas la même oreille sur ces photos
et donc qu'ils ont dit notre oreille et
les uniques et quand l'oreille ne
correspond pas sûr sur les personnes
c'est que il ya un problème par rapport
au ca personnage à la mi-mars cela vous
le voyez dans cet immense stade de
moscou avec sa grosse doudoune bas juste
après la guerre justement y avait l'air
très en forme à savoir la wii mais
justement allez on dit la grosse
doudoune pourquoi la grosse doudoune
parce que c'est peut-être aussi pour
cacher les vraies formes de ceux de ces
personnes la même chose pour quand il a
prononcé les voeux c'était très bizarre
on avait l'impression qu'il avait trois
gilet pare-balles sous son manteau le 31
décembre quand elles affronteront soit
10 sous le discours pourtant c'est un
discours enregistré donc tout était
contrôlé etc il était pas seul et il
n'est pas seul maintenant seulement
maintenant c'est devenu déjà un problème
pendant le coc vide par un kobe de l'avs
ai la trouille de quid donc là il ses
banques et reese est ici là il a éloigné
toutes les personnes qui sont autour de
lui et vous avez vu
c'est devenu un mème donc je sais pas si
vous avez vu tout les tous les trucs que
les anciens sur internet de vidéos sur
sur internet sur ses méthodes vous avez
parlé de petites empoisonnement où il
est soupçonné d'avoir empoisonné alexeï
navalni son premier opposant il a muselé
la presse libre il a fait assassiner
pratiquement tous nous tous les
journalistes qui pouvait s'opposer à lui
raisons politiques mais les hommes
politiques comme neda est ce que cette
répression systématique c'est c'est nous
les occidentaux qu'ils n'avaient pas
compris sa dimension est ce que c'est où
est ce que c'est un peu nouveau ça s'est
installée ou c'était là depuis le début
c'était dès le début dès le début parce
que il y avait déjà galine star avoue y
sava qui était la députée de leningrad
qu'il a connu quand il était encore sous
sobczak un petit oreiller du tout un
petit sbires qui lui réservait les taxis
et servait et porter les serviettes
quand il a gagné son premier million de
dollars sur les magouilles sur l'aide
humanitaire allemande qui était envoyé
l'hymne god égal il faisait partie de la
commission d' enquête qui a trouvé
toutes les tout ça il a été assassiné à
saint-pétersbourg salut c'est aussi un
livre sur la tentative de médiation des
manuels macron qui a multiplié les coups
de téléphone même après boudhha même
après les découvertes des massages
jusqu'à maintenant les crimes de guerre
sert à quoi ça sert je crois que
sincèrement emmanuel macron
sous-estiment amont à mon avis de
poutine et il croit que on pourra on
peut encore négocier avec lui parce que
justement il est tellement isolé dans le
monde que peut-être lui témoigner cet
intérêt ils pouvaient le sortir un tout
petit peu son bon coeur donc là je suis
très pessimiste par rapport à ça mais en
même temps je dis dans le livre dans
toutes les interviews que je donne que
emmanuel macron c'est peut-être la seule
personne ou une des rares personnes dans
le monde qui quand ils se trouvent comme
ça avec cette table même s'il ya 5 m ou
6 mètres entre eux il est coutume face à
lui et il peut lui dire dans les yeux ce
qu'il pense et je crois que c'est c'est
une des rares personnes qui est capable
de lui de dire à poutine parce que tous
les autres ont peur vous avez vu menace
chine le directeur de sfr guillet le 21
qui qui était humiliée en public
vous imaginez que cette personne va lui
dire la vérité sur le poulet j'ai
rencontré plusieurs fois vous avez vu
cette ascension progressive cette cette
manière dit il est finalement devenu un
autocrate brutale la menace nucléaire
faut la prendre au sérieux ou pas moi je
la prends très au sérieux moi je la
prends très au sérieux parce que
justement c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
je raconte cette histoire de l'institut
andropov en situant d'eau peuvent non
seulement n'a pas voulu lui
l'école d'édition de moscou et le
service d'espionnage mais ils ont ils
ont surtout mis une qualification c'est
une personne qui ne qui ne peut pas
prévoir la contre les conséquences
la dangerosité des conséquences qui des
décisions qu'il prend et ça peut être
dangereux pour lui pour le service et
vous voyez le kgb à dix en 1985 et donc
ils sont pas trompés et mais maintenant
cette personne possède la moitié de
l'arsenal nucléaire du monde a fait
preuve d' aveuglement nous les
occidentaux
c'est pas la veille aurait aussi nos
faiblesses je crois que c'est assez
c'est un tout petit peu la paresse
intellectuelle après l'intérêt aussi un
peu de lâcheté enfin il ya vous savez on
a pas on n'a pas envie de d'avoir une
confrontation avec un pays qui possède
la moitié de leurs sionnel nucléaire
avant mondiale donc du coup et pillent
ça rend des services à tous les gens qui
gagnent de l'argent soit en investissant
nous aussi soit un important sont en
exportant donc ça tout s'explique alors
comment vous voyez la suite de ce
conflit qui a commencé il ya plus de
trois mois maintenant on sait que la
ville de severodonezk et près de tomber
ça voudrait dire que le dombass seraient
prêtes tombée est-ce que encore les
ukrainiens ne le lâcheront jamais les
ukrainiens n'accepterons pas une
partition du donbass sévère de nexeya
c'est la république c'est le blast de
lougansk donc là elle est quasiment
quasiment envahi dombass hermantier
c'est seulement la moitié dont car il ya
encore enfin la de la région donnait ce
qu il ya encore du territoire les
ukrainiens ont prouvé maintenant qu'ils
peuvent faire face
d'une manière conventionnelle à l'armée
de poutine qui s'est révélé être une
petite armée finalement parce que tout
le monde disait la deuxième
les ukrainiens avec les armes 6 av si
les ukrainiens avaient les armes lourdes
ils peuvent gagner les gars en ont des
armes et n'ont livré par les américains
on leur a promis et canon caesar les
canons caesar eux ils sont arrivés en
revanche l'aide américaine met du temps
à venir parce que c'est c'est une grosse
machine d'abord il fallait voter après
il fallait acheminés après ça se fait
mine par la pologne entre pologne et
l'est de l'ukraine il ya 1200 kg et 1300
km donc tout ça ça prend du temps mais
les ukrainiens peuvent gagner ça et
c'est justement ça le danger parce que 6
du décret ni à gagner avec les armes
conventionnelles poutine sera tellement
déçu et tellement
comment dire
a.ayew riz par sept par cette victoire
qu'il est capable d'utiliser
tout est sombre avertissement ça
s'appelle l'engrenage 7 aux éditions
albin michel ça sort là juste là
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui même sur tous
merci beaucoup sergei mais remercie ses
regards jrgn vous restez avec nous
d'ailleurs tout ce que vous nous avez
dit est vrai est ce qu on pressent qu'on
peut cesser d'être un espion ou quelque
part on le reste à pompe lors on peut si
c'est oui on peut si si c'est vrai c'est
ouais bah écoutez vous restez avec nous
tous les cas parce que c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos a franchi pour leur
parti pris j'ai nommé ce soir elsa monde
un gars vaille son carnet de campagne
sur les législatives elle va nous parler
de cette inquiétude qui monte au sein de
la majorité avant ce scrutin d'économies
avec fanny guinochet croissance faible
inflation record attention au cocktail
de la récession et puis l'international
isabelle lasserre quand les diplomates
fait rarissime font la grève elle
commence demain bonsoir mesdames les
affranchis au féminin pluriel les voix
si on va commencer avec vous l amont
d'un gars va carnet de campagne comme
chaque soir sur les légistes et id petit
vent de panique est ce qu'on peut dire
ça en tout cas vent d'inquiétude dans la
majorité à dix jours du premier tour
exactement plusieurs soldats cela myriam
évidemment déjà tous les hommes et les
femmes politiques jure la main sur le
coeur qui ne regarde jamais les sondages
c'est faux ils en parlent tous et il
voit dans ces sondages et bien que la
majorité pourrait disposer d'une
majorité moins confortable que prévu
peut-être pas la majorité absolue ici à
l'assemblée c'est à dire 289 sièges
c'est quand même le scénario pessimiste
et on le rappelle les sondages c'est
très compliqué avec les législatives
parce qu'en fait c'est 577 élections
locales deuxième source d'inquiétude ça
n'a échappé à personne les premiers pas
du gouvernement d'elisabeth bornes ne se
sont pas forcément passé comme prévu à
peine nommé il ya eu l' affaire abah
depuis ce week-end le fiasco de
l'organisation de la finale de la ligue
des champions alors j'ai interrogé
plusieurs députés plusieurs candidats
qui font campagne ils me disent que sur
leur terrain ne leur en parle pas
beaucoup ce vraiment
dont on leur part c'est le pouvoir
d'achat alors ça le gouvernement elle
avait plutôt anticiper sauf
qu'apparemment c'est plus compliqué que
ça sur le terrain pas plus compliqué que
prévu puisque le texte il viendra après
les élections législatives puisque s'il
était arrivé avant il aurait fallu
convoquer une commission des finances et
puis en plus on est en période de
réserve alors les candidats ils peuvent
quand même vendre les mesures sur le
terrain puisqu'il y en a certaines qu'on
connaît déjà l'indexation des pensions
de retraite le dégel du point d'indicé
oui mais par exemple sur le chèque
alimentaire on n'a pas encore exactement
le chiffrage le fléchage sur les loyers
on ne sait pas encore quelles mesures
vont être prises bref ça ne facilite pas
le travail d'explication quelle est la
stratégie alors que co perd la majorité
qu'utilise la majorité bah il part
vraiment à l'offensive l'offensive
contre son ennemi désigné c'est jean luc
mélenchon et la nuque dans les mots tout
d'abord elisabeth bornes la première
ministre parle de danger bruno le maire
le ministre de l'économie comparé jean
luc mélenchon à chavez gaulois et dans
les images bien regarder ces visuels ils
ont inondé les comptes twitter un des
candidats de la majorité avec le jeu de
mots nous sommes allés voir s'afficher
pour nos invités également à lézinnes
continuer le jeu de mots nous ne sommes
pas dupes transformer en hashtag nous ne
sommes pas nul regardez par exemple
christophe castaner le patron des
députés ici à l'assemblée alors lui il
les a tous posté il ya onze visuel il
les a tous mis sur son compte et pour la
majorité mais jean-luc mélenchon c'est
pêle mêle des risques de pénurie des
enfants sans repère une attaque inédite
à la laïcité l'arrière où les vins d'une
france forte voici ces visuels cette
offensive c'est un peu un aveu c'est que
cette union de la gauche elle fait quand
même un peu peur à la majorité et puis
c'est aussi un risque puisque cela
risque peut-être d'un de su remobiliser
l'électorat de la nouba on verra ça en
tout cas voilà c'est vrai ces visuels là
il se réveille il se réveille et ça en
dit long sur l'inquiétude
l'inquiétude c'est aussi la situation
économique finir un chiffre alarmant ce
soir l'inflation déjà 5,2 pour cent sur
un an on n'a pas vu ça depuis 37 ans et
malheureusement c'est pas terminé il va
falloir s'y habituer effectivement au
moins quelques mois parce que les prix
de l'énergie et il pèse lourd dans ce
chiffre d'inflation c'est à peu près la
moitié est bien les prix de l'énergie
ont vois pas comment ils vont et alors
que le conflit entre la russie et
l'ukraine a l'air de s'enliser je parle
sous votre contrôle alors que la chine
reste alors certes elle se des consignes
peu à peu mais on voit bien que les
chaînes d'approvisionnement restent
encore très bousculée et puis il ya
aussi des aléas climatiques c'est ce qui
fait que il ya eu un certain nombre de
pénurie c'était avant le coc vie d'un on
le sait les sécheresses a eu des
sécheresses ici ou là des tempêtes qui
ont fait que on a des récoltes qui sont
où il ya des tensions sur les récoltes
alors cette inflation n'y était pas du
tout habitués mais c'est vrai qu'on voit
al est multifactorielle et c'est ce qui
fait que c'est très difficile de la
contrée alors le gouvernement vous en
parlait comme c'est le pouvoir d'achat
c'est la préoccupation numéro un des
français fait tout pour essayer de la
contenir on écoute bruno le maire qui
quand même nous prévient ça va être un
pic je vous laisse je laisse écouter le
du couserans pic inflationniste qui
devrait durer encore quelques mois
pascal guerre en ukraine parce qu'il
faut trouver un approvisionnement en gaz
et en pétrole qui se substitue à
l'approvisionnement russe que le marché
chinois aujourd'hui est bloquée et vers
la fin de l'année 2022 je l'espère début
2023 on devrait déjà commencer à voir
s'amorcer une inflation plus faible
alors feignasses que le gouvernement ont
fait assez contre contre l'inflation et
pour le pouvoir d'achat en tout cas on
peut dire qu'ils se mobilisent un on
attend ce fameux texte dont vous parliez
sur le pouvoir d'achat après les
législatives mais déjà là en campagne il
promet un certain nombre de mesures ils
dépensent des milliards par exemple on
sait déjà qu'il y aura un bouclier
tarifaire sur le gaz et sur
l'électricité et c'est pas un homme
c'est un bouclier morceaux voilà c'est
une opération plus de 20 milliards
d'euros en tout cas quand on fait
l'opération grosso modo
et ça fonctionne plutôt bien parce que
certes quand on est dans les rayons se
dit que c'est vraiment très cher mais on
est moins frappée nous français par
l'inflation que ne le sont nos voisins
notamment nos voisins 10% en grèce 9
quasiment voilà en allemagne vous
regardez l'espagne c'est pareil
quasiment 10% chez nos amis les belges
c'est vrai que la zone euro en moyenne
ces 8 % alors le problème évidemment
c'est que derrière ces chiffres tout le
monde n'est pas frappé de la même façon
les français ne sont pas frappés du même
façon les plus modestes évidemment
souffre beaucoup parce que c'est très
concret on s'en rend compte tous les
jours on va faire ses courses et déjà on
voit dans les achats il ya des vrais
changements qui s'opèrent
quand vous avez des pâtes à plus de 15%
quand vous avez de la viande la viande
surgelée + 18 % et bien les ménages les
plus modestes notamment font des
arbitrages exit tous les achats plaisir
exit un certain nombre de produits même
des produits d'hygiène que les français
n'achètent plus alors ce qu'il faut dans
ces conditions là c'est monter les
salaires et le gouvernement et la
pression sur les entreprises ce qui peut
réussir à les forcer à faire un geste
alors ça a l'air simple mais ce matin
geoffroy roux de bézieux qui était à
france info disait je peux pas appuyer
sur un bouton comme ça et demandé à
toutes les entreprises d'augmenter les
salaires déjà parce qu'elles ne peuvent
pas certaines font des marges mais
d'autres ne peuvent pas le faire parce
qu'elles ont elles mêmes elles subissent
l'inflation elles ont elles mêmes des
matériaux qui augmente et puis il ya un
vrai risque aujourd'hui c'est le risque
de cette spirale inflationniste c'est à
dire que vous augmentez les salaires
mais pour augmenter les salaires vous
augmentez vos prix donc forcément le
consommateur il paye plus cher donc il
dit bah je vais retourner voir mon
patron pour demander une augmentation de
salaire et puis la passe est très très
dangereux la machine taxe on l'a
déjà vu dans les années 80 cette spirale
le gouvernement veut à tout prix
l'éviter bon ben on espère que voilà ces
mesures permettront dès d'y parvenir à
vous intéresser sergueï mironov isabelle
lasserre va nous parler d'un drôle de
mouvements franchement mouvement de
grève mouvement de grève au quai d'orsay
parmi les diplomates c'est la deuxième
fois seulement dans l'histoire du quai
d'orsay que les diplomates se mobilisent
et se met voilà au chômage volontaire en
tout cas se mettent en grève
c'est sûr que c'est plus grave c'est
plus rare qu'à la sncf ou à l'air dp 1
puisque d'habitude les diplomates sont
plutôt connus pour leur loyauté au
pouvoir vis-à-vis du pouvoir exécutif
que pour le goût de leur goût de la
rébellion et les grèves c'est pas
vraiment dans la culture d'une maison
qui est plutôt conservatrice mais cette
fois en fait la coupe était vraiment
plein encore en cours en cause pardon
c'est une réforme une réforme du corps
diplomatique qui leur a été imposé de
manière un petit peu brutale par
l'elysée dans le cadre de la réforme de
la haute fonction publique
dont les nay le corps préfectoral ont
déjà fait les frais alors depuis qu'elle
a été annoncée c'est très rare elle a
fait absolument l'unanimité contre elle
concrètement la suppression ou plutôt
selon les termes du décret qui était
publié la mise en extinction comme
stipule l'accord diplomatique des deux
corps historique de la diplomatie celui
des ministres plénipotentiaires et celui
des conseillers des affaires étrangères
veut dire que les diplomates seront à
l'avenir choisi dans une espèce de pot
commun qui va réunir tous les hauts
fonctionnaires de toutes les autres
administrations mais alors est ce que
c'est si grave que ça qui est un petit
peu de mobilité parmi les hauts
fonctionnaires est ce que c'est la
disparition de la diplomatie
professionnels qui oui puisque qui nous
guette si on pousse un peu le bouchon si
on exagère un petit peu on peut tout à
fait imaginer un sous préfet de lozère
qui
baladeur
ou
alors un représentant du secteur privé
qu'il faudrait remercier pour des
services rendus qui serait nommé à
berlin ou à rome donc en fait finalement
les compétences l'expérience la
connaissance des langues tout ça passe
au second plan derrière les objectifs de
diversification et de transversalité
avancée par l'elysée or pour être
efficace il faut pas que la diplomatie
soit transversale mais elle doit surtout
être menée par des spécialistes qui
connaissent leur métier qu'ils ont
appris sur le terrain dont les
connaissances acquises au fil des années
à l'étranger leur permettre de
comprendre leur pays de déjouer les
pièges et d'influencé
de de transmettre la vaillance de la
france mais lorsque ce que vous nous
dites c'est que
elles menaceraient cette réforme notre
influence l'affluence de la france à
l'étranger vraiment mais oui parce que
en fait la france inde l'un des
meilleurs corps diplomatique du monde ce
corps diplomatique est enviée par toutes
les grandes capitales et si la réforme
est appliquée telle quelle la france
sera le seul grand pays occidental à ne
plus avoir de diplomates professionnels
alors le quai d'orsay risque de perdre
une partie de son expertise et donc de
sa compréhension du monde et le risque
d'érosion de l' influence de la france
dans le monde est d'autant plus grave
enfin plus plus plus grand que la
réforme en fait s'ajoute à une une
marginalisation progressive du ministère
des affaires étrangères elle est
provoquée par la baisse des moyens
depuis plusieurs années aussi par la
présidentialisation de la politique
étrangère surtout depuis l'arrivée
d'emmanuel mcrae qui n'a jamais vraiment
aimé les diplomates et les lots quai
d'orsay qui est une machine trop lente
et trop lourde pour le hockey s'est dit
ça s'appelle un parti pris vous avez une
poignée de secondes tout sur cette
réforme où je connaissais bien 7 ans
j'ai fait l'ena et j'ai fait l'école
diplomatique aussi de moscou
je comprends très bien c'est un lobby
aussi un petit répit sans presque par
exemple si on prenait les états unis les
états unis n'ont pas d'écoles de
formation diplomate ce sont les grandes
universités américaines qui fournissent
les diplomates ils sont aussi compétents
que les autres merci à vous servir même
si on l'utilisé la fin de cette émission
merci à vous de m'avoir suivi tout de
suite à votre soirée documentaire avec
infirmer ces pays n'est dit sur les
cours criminelles signé l'éthicien
ohnona premier bilan de cette
expérimentation destinée à désengorger
les tribunaux très belle soirée à demain
[Musique]